je pense que nous pouvons collectivement
affirmer que la société française
traverse de puissantes transformations
notre rôle exécutif comme législatif est
de le comprendre de les accompagner dans
le cadre d'un Pact républicain rénové
mais exigeant en matière de parentalité
le sujet est d'actualité dans nos
permanences parlementaires nous
recueillons les témoignages de certains
parents quelquefois dépassés d'autresfis
isolés face à à la charge des
responsabilités qui leur incombent nous
avons de plus en plus de maires isolés
qui reconnaissent être en difficulté
pour assurer une charge parentale qui
pourtant devrait être pleinement
partagée et assurée par les Pères par
ailleurs nous entendons des enseignants
nous dire que leur autorité est de plus
en plus contestée nous entendons des
policiers des gendarmes nous expliquer
être de plus en plus défillés par des
adolescents livrés à eux-mêmes comme
dans toute chose par ailleurs les
Français attendent un choc de
responsabilité mais plus encore un choc
d'autorité ils attendent que nous
bâtissions des politiques publi
cohérente et globale pour favoriser la
natalité cibler la maîtrise des savoirs
fondamentaux et inciter à la
responsabilité et à l'autorité parentale
des mesures fortes ont été récemment
annoncées allant à la mise en place de
travaux d'intérêt général pour les
parents défaillants à l'accompagnement
des parents en difficulté mesure que
nous souten non pleinement aussi madame
la Première ministre pouvez-vous
préciser à la représentation nationale
les grandes orientations de votre
ambition en ces domaines je vous en
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
député la parole est à monsieur Éric DUP
Moretti garde d' saau ministre de la
Justice madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Royer
per le lendemain du début des émutes
j'ai dit tenez tenez vos gosses et en
quelques jours il faut le dire l'ordre
républicain a été rétabli grâce aux
forces de sécurité intérieure grâce au
magistrat il fallait alors analyser la
situation et on a constaté que de
nombreux émetiers étaient des gamin tout
jeune très jeune trop jeune c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a mis en place
un certain nombre de mesures et je veux
ici chaleureusement remercier Aurore
berger pour son aide et son analyse
toujours très précieuse voilà les
mesures voilà les mesures qui vont être
annoncées très prochainement au Conseil
des ministres le texte naturellement a
été soumis au Conseil d'État des travaux
d'intérêt général pour les parents
défaillants je dis bien pour les parents
défaillons ceux qui n'assurent pas leur
responsabilité de sécurité de moralité
d'éducation de leurs enfants ne vous en
déplaisent ensuite condamnation des
parents qui ne se rendent pas aux
audiences de leurs enfants c'est ça le
rétablissement de l'autorité parentale
une mesure de contribution citoyenne
éducative qui sera versé aux
associations de défense des enfants
maltraités les deux parents seront
responsables même s'ils sont séparés et
si la garde de l'enfant est attribuée à
l'un des deux enfin c'est une création
un accueil de nuit des mineurs prise en
charge par la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse pour ne pas que ces enfants
ces gamins s'il vous plaît tra
Dansou si vous
continuez que les choses soient claires
monsieur le député ça ne concerne pas
les parents qui sont dépassés évidemment
qu'il faut aider ça concerne ceux qui
n'assument pas leur responsabilité merci
beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
allez-y merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre d'avoir précisé les
intentions du Gouvernement je crois
qu'effectivement faut que nous soyons
sur une politique globale et équilibré
une politique qui accompagne les parents
qui comme vous le dites sont dépassés
nous comptons sur l'action de la
ministre des Solidarités et de la
famille et bien évidemment une politique
qui soit plusci beaucoup merci mon cher
collègue